do you guys want to hear something crazy
I just found out Manny Pacquiao is
running for the for president hold on
2022 policies for a long time yeah but
that I don't think he even went to
elementary school yeah yeah he was on
the Fox Sports the other day
so obviously yeah did you see that no so
the UFC was on fs1 Fox and obviously is
switched to ESPN now and they've got PBC
which is supposed to fill in that void
for FS 1 which is premier boxing
champions or something like that
and there's a big fight this weekend
that Adrien Broner taking on Manny
Pacquiao and they've got like their
boxing version of UFC tonight so they
got a few boxing guys on there they got
version of Karen Bryan and they had
Manny Pacquiao on there I stumbled
across it through the Dallas watches oh
[ __ ] cuz I used to work on that show so
I want to see and it's very very similar
to UFC tonight same kind of feel
everything was just boxing not UFC yeah
and as I say Manny Pacquiao was on there
and he said basketball times in a roll
but that's why I like he was so beloved
in a country because everyone wants to
hear is we're a third world country the
Philippines we are we are the best now
I'm telling your day that my next-door
neighbors make me hate myself because
they're so good they're so nice and why
I'm a [ __ ] yeah they come over every
time with gifts presents and you [ __ ]
name anytime at a fight that bring
things all the flowers and champagne and
this at Christmas they come up with gift
cards for the kids thoughtful presents
and stuff and we have nothing again I
grab like the perfume I bought from a
wife on my thing
this is open so you have no they're
awesome you're like that too when we go
to a party she's like we got to stop by
and get wine crackers and all that's
something I'm lying
Filipinos should know our profession is
hospitality come to the Philippines the
red carpet will be rolled out for you in
a way that's different from any other
country you'll ever step foot in it's
just what we do we're hospital we land
that's nice
yeah it's Cebu when we landed you had a
whole band and dance and people are
dancing and then when we left they just
compact up and left hold on that dance
here was not for us sweetie they're just
always dancing there for anybody all
right
what I'm saying I don't think they were
for me I know that but where do you see
that ever it's true but on that same
note this is why Manny Pacquiao is sort
of dangerous because he is so beloved
for being the sweet kind of simple guy
sure you don't elect a man like that in
two years crazy ideas he has religion
he's a good guy I believe the gate what
does he think of gay people he's a good
guy probably not a good thing yeah just
right right [ __ ] idiots
yeah yeah yeah I'm sorry yeah every
religious person in the world it's like
when my next-door neighbors are very
religious and they're not [ __ ] idiots
the Filipinos yeah yeah yeah in England
[Music]